Charlie murphy told us a story of you and him coming over your house in a
limousine and you had a,
it wasn't a lion or a tiger tiger.
He must though the line for had the tag it.
What made you think you could get a tiger?
Like how did that even happen?
Hey,
I'm in.
Um,
and so,
um,
I'm in prison at the time,
so I'm in prison.
I'm talking to my car dealer at the time and he had caused that,
belonged to a friend of mine and he's discussing the feet up and painful these
cars.
I'm a fellow leave cards to someone and get them horses and stuff.
I said,
well you can get ahold of him.
Wasn't there for card cause I hadn't a lot of cards.
I probably get some orthos yeah,
me get cool.
Good Lions Tigers that you do.
Can you get me some packages?
Yeah.
And the guy told me and the guy from my man,
how cool.
That'd be big being an Athema for Rami.
You have a tiger right next to you,
man.
I'm saying to myself,
wow,
that would be cool,
right?
Yeah.
Get me some cousins,
man.
And then I came home.
I had go cubs right there waiting for me.
Now he never gets,
this is a crazy picture.
You and your underwear with a tiger on a chain that is,
that is one of the,
that's the dance right there.
That's you at peak.
Crazy.
Yeah.
And thing.
I was going through my mind.
Yeah.
No,
it made me think about my friends.
You can get from our,
from animal.
Nothing really.
I'm going to get from a whole life.
Everybody does it though.
Those are one of the things of about,
uh,
what's his face from narcos.
Oh,
Pablo West Cobb,
Alaska.
He got like a fucking zoo or had a whole crazy zoo.
They all do it,
but you get like that rich,
you're like,
just get some animal.
Yeah.
You want to fuck with the animal.
And they show people in the with the line.
The Tiger,
Huh?
Yeah.
You mother fucker.